gestern spät nachts wurden in hanau neun
personen mit migrationshintergrund
erschossen
sechs weitere personen wurden verletzt
davon eine person schwer
kurze zeit später wurde der mutmaßliche
täter zusammen mit seiner mutter in
seiner wohnung tot aufgefunden ebenfalls
augenscheinlich erschossen
neben dem mutmaßlichen täter wurde eine
schusswaffe aufgefunden
auf der homepage des mutmaßlichen täters
er hatte er videobotschaften und eine
art manifest eingestellt die neben
wirren gedanken und abstrusen
verschwörungstheorien aber eine zutiefst
rassistische gesinnung aufweisen
deswegen habe ich die ermittlungen in
diesem fall an mich gezogen
in absprache mit dem generalstaatsanwalt
aus frankfurt ziel der ermittlungen
unsere ermittlungen wird sein
herauszufinden ob es für diese anschläge
in hanau mitwisser oder unterstützern
gab oder gibt dazu werden wir das umfeld
und die kontakte des mutmaßlichen täters
abklären
sowohl hier im inland aber auch kontakte
die er möglicherweise ins ausland gehabt
hat mit den polizeilichen ermittlungen
in diesem fall habe ich das
bundeskriminalamt beauftragt das
bundeskriminalamt wird in diesem fall
unterstützt durch das hessische kriminal
landeskriminalamt dass auch die ersten
ermittlungen heute übernommen hat mein
mitgefühl ist bei den angehörigen der
opfer den verletzten wünsche ich baldige
und vollständige genesung es ist ein tag
oder eine nacht die uns noch lange in
erinnerung bleiben wird und die unsere
weitere ermittlungsarbeit stark prägen
wird
vielen dank gut so weiß der
generalbundesanwalt dr peter frank live
aus karlsruhe war dass gerade ich warte
jetzt irgendwas überraschendes für dich
dabei naja so richtig überraschend
nichts hat sich bestätigt eben dieses
einschreiten des generalbundesanwalts
eben weil es eben diese rassistische
ganz klar rassistische motivlage neben
diesen wirren gedanken gut wobei man
sagen muss nur weil jemand wird ist und
geistesgestört möglicherweise heißt das
ja nicht dass es nicht auch
rechtsextremist kann ja eben hand in
hand gehen geht eben oft hand in hand
und deswegen kann ihm trotzdem der
generalbundesanwalt ermitteln obwohl er
wie gesagt möglicherweise eine schwere
psychische störung hatte aber
interessante sagte die sind sich
offensichtlich sicher dass der täter ist
dann auch noch vom mutmaßlichen täter
das war eine frage die hier auftauchte
warum wird die ganze zeit von mutmaßlich
meinen mehr beweis leider gibts ja quasi
gar nicht mal so das ist ja ein mann der
behörde ist generalbundesanwalts und da
kann es eben zum guten ton dass man
solange jetzt noch nicht vollständig aus
ermittelt es von einem mutmaßlichen
täter spricht aber es zeigt uns ja
worüber was soll jetzt noch weiter
ermittelt werden und da wurde jetzt
nicht erwähnt ob er wirklich der täter
ist sondern was noch ermittelt werden
sollte es gibt es hintermänner mitwisser
dann geht er wirklich gänzlich alleine
darauf ist jetzt der fokus gerichtet
dass dieser mann die tat begangen hat
davon scheinen die sehr überzeugt zu
sagen ja es gibt ja dieses material was
online war und nicht mehr online ist und
falls ihr das zufällig finden solltet im
internet möchten wir euch ganz herzlich
darum bitten dass nicht weiter zu
verteilen damit solche gedanken eben
nicht noch mehr menschen erreichen
felix du hast das ja auch teilweise
gelesen dieses jahr wie soll man das
nennen so eine art rechtfertigung
erklärung seines weltbildes und der tat
kannst du mal kurz zusammenfassen wir
das versucht zu begründen was er getan
hat
also wirklich völlig völlig absurd er
fängt erst mal an
seiten führte aus dass er schon seit ein
bibel ist abgehört wird von einem
geheimen die nicht näher bezeichneter
geheimer so verschwörungstheorie absolut
verschwörungstheorien und dieser
geheimdienst also der hat sozusagen
irrsinnige möchte der kann sogar seine
gedanken lesen also muss noch nicht mal
abgehört werden und dann geht es aber
relativ zügig auch dazu dass er von
eigener erfahrung spricht und denen er
irgendwann einmal negative erfahrungen
gemacht hat mit sogenannter
ausländerkriminalität wie er sagt und
kommt dann schnell zu dem schluss dass
das ja unterliegende völker seiner und
die müssten alle vernichtet werden so
und die werden ja auch äußerlich und
sowieso völlig unansehnlich hatte ganz
wie der generalbundesanwalt gesagt habe
zutiefst rassistische gedanken aber die
verweben sich dann immer wieder mit
diesen wirren theorien
denn warum sollen die völker vernichtet
werden aus seiner mutter seinem
begründungen warum sein haus nämlich
weil das große ziel der welt war ja den
sinn des lebens zu entdecken und das
könne man nicht wenn auf der erde noch
weiterhin minderwertige bevölkerungen
völker sein würde dann müsste man jetzt
nur die deutsche bevölkerung oder auch
paar andere völker sind auch noch mit
zugelassen aber alle anderen müssen
vernichtet werden
also das ist ja ganz klar rassistisch
schon geht so in richtung ja fast
faschistischen nazi denken dass wir
unter verschiedenes nazi denkt aber mit
immer gepaart mit einer kruden theorien
und da gibt es ja sehr viele davon im
internet
das stimmt leider wir haben dazu mal den
rechtsextremismus experten und
journalisten
ich höre gerade aus der regie um euch
alle auf den neuesten stand der
ermittlungen zu bringen der
generalbundesanwalt war gerade schon vor
den kameras hat gesagt er zieht die
ermittlungen an sich weil es sich hier
um einen rechts terroristischen akt
handelt für den er zuständig ist aber
falls ihr nicht ganz mitbekommen habt
was heute nach den hanau passiert ist
ein attentat auf das leben von mir
mittlerweile zehn menschen hier ein
zusammenschnitt ein überblick von
isabelle de la vega hanau
die stadt ist heute mit der
schrecklichen nachricht des attentats
erwacht im zentrum der stadt und im
westen in der nähe der beiden tatorte
zeigen
ich die anwohner erschüttert von der
nachricht der vielen toten
[Musik]
zumal das hat ziemlich offene stadt ist
auch für ausländer die halt eben auch
hier ist sehr willkommen sind und in der
stadt hat gestern nacht gegen 22 uhr im
zentrum am heumarkt schießt ein mann in
der shisha bar mit neid um sich und
tötet vier menschen das video eines
anwohners zeigt bilder wenige minuten
nach der tat da war der täter offenbar
schon weitergefahren in richtung westen
zum kurt schumacher platz in kesselstadt
er vertritt dort einen kiosk und
erschießt fünf menschen dem
kioskbesitzer bot sich ein bild des
schreckens abgesehen 50 leute liegen auf
dem boden zwei hinter der theke 2 also
alles total blutbad
mein neffe beraterinnen mitarbeiter
alles tut der attentäter fährt dann
offenbar weiter zu seiner wohnung in der
nähe
die polizei nimmt die spur auf und
findet nachdem sie die tür aufbricht
zwei leichen die des mutmaßlichen täters
und die seiner mutter
bald wird auch offiziell bestätigt dass
es sich um ein attentat mit
rechtsextremistischem hintergrund
handeln könne
die opfer seien vor allem türken die
polizei findet ein schreiben des täters
mit wirr verschwörungstheorien und
voller ausländer hass auf einem video im
netz ist laut sicherheitskreisen der
täter tobias r zu sehen als sportschütze
besitzt er einen waffenschein
polizeilich auffällig war bisher nicht
ja diese frage nach dem waffenschein die
möchte ich es nochmal felix zimmermann
stellen aus unserer redaktion recht und
justiz der mann war offenkundig ja man
kann sagen gestört bzw mit einem
rechtsextremen rechtsextremistischen
sehr merkwürdigen weltbild ausgestattet
und war sportschütze
wie geht das zusammen
ja da muss aber vielleicht mal nach der
zeitlichen dimension fragen war er
möglicherweise mit diesem gedanken wird
schon ausgestattet also diesen schein
beantragt hat vielleicht war es dann
noch nicht
das würde im schlampig geprüft aber was
auf jeden fall auf feld in dem
bekennerschreiben steht mehr vertreten
dass er ganz viele anzeigen gestellt hat
also querulant erotische anzeigen und
wenn die auch nur ansatzweise so will
sind ja wie dieses bekennerschreiben und
so radikal so radikal dann musst du den
behörden ist vielleicht auch mal
aufgefallen sein
und da kann man schon mal nachfragen es
ist jetzt noch nicht genau ob man dann
dass man hätte nach kontrollieren müssen
wer ist das eigentlich hat er hat
darüber einen waffenschein
also stellt sich schon fragen warum da
nicht etwas engmaschiger kontrolliert
wurde
väter bei der justiz und auch bei den
behörden ein bisschen noch der blick
dafür dass man nicht nur in die eine
ecke guckt wo man islamistische
gefährder vermutet und sagt da die
dürfen auf gar keinen fall irgendwie an
waffen kommen sondern dass man auch
tatsächlich nach solchen hinweisen sucht
aus der sogenannten mitte der
gesellschaft dass leute auffällig werden
ja ganz video sagt wenn wir jetzt
mehrfach solche vorfälle auch will
gruppe es die da am wochenende letzten
wochen eine hochgenommen wurde das waren
leute die ganz in der mitte der
gesellschaft stehen und da richteten
sich schon die behördlichen blicke drauf
haben ja gesehen diese gruppe wurde
hochgenommen
aber die haben nun auch regel sich
ausgetauscht in chats auf facebook das
ist natürlich für ermittlungsbehörden
sehr viel leichter als bei so jemanden
der nach bisherigem kenntnisstand eben
sich selbst radikalisierte durch
verschwörungstheorien aber hast ja auch
schon vorgespräche zu recht gesagt ganz
selbst ist das natürlich nicht weil das
sind ja diese ideologien und die hat ja
auch jemand zustande gebracht und
stellen sich den netzwerken halten aber
vor schluss ist irrt vermutlich wir
haben den rechtsextremismus experten und
journalisten urlaub sundermeier mal
gefragt der sich lange mit diesem ganzen
thema beschäftigt ob ihnen dieses
attentat jetzt überrascht hat und er hat
folgendes gesagt wir müssen in
deutschland jederzeit damit rechnen dass
so etwas passiert
den fehler den man gemacht hat auch über
die politik über den sicherheitsbehörden
ist dass man den leuten in der
vergangenheit gesagt hat dass
rechtsextremisten
nur gibt wenn sie organisiert sind wenn
die sicherheitsbehörden sie kennen dass
es mitnichten der fall
wir haben eine hoch aufgeladene
fremdenfeindliche rassistische
politische klimaveränderung in
deutschland seit einigen seit einigen
jahren und menschen wie dieser
mutmaßliche täter sähen sich ermutigt
dass sie auch nicht alleine sind von
ihrem umfeld auch aus möglicherweise aus
dem internet zu sagen ich tue etwas was
viele menschen genauso sehen insofern
hat mich das nicht so sehr überrascht
wir schauen mal kurz in die kommentare
weil auf youtube gibt es so eine sache
über die wir gerne mit euch reden
möchten hier schreibt so nah yalcin er
war nazi und nicht verwirrt das ist
natürlich ja eine ein einwand dass wir
jetzt gesagt haben das weltbild dass
dieser tobias er da von sich gegeben hat
wirkt verwirrt
felix wir haben gerade schon gesagt das
muss sich nicht gegenseitig ausschließen
häufig das kennen wir auch von
islamistischen gefährdern oder
terroristen haben die ja ähnlich rudel
weltbilder ja das ist irgendwo die frage
wenn ein weltbild sei es auch noch so
abstrus wie das wenn ich einen mord
begehen den himmel kommen und jungfrauen
auf mich warten wenn das irgendwie schon
etabliert ist und sagt man das ist
terrorismus man eine gute ideen sich
zusammenwürfelt dann sagt man es wird ja
das verstehe ich dass das nicht so
bleiben kann
aber es ist einfach nicht zu übersehen
dass der jetzt nicht an einer klaren
ideologie folgt sondern eben ein ganzes
konglomerat an ihren ideen hat und
aufregung gericht eigentlich eine rolle
das kann vor gericht natürlich jetzt
eine rolle spielen wo es um die frage
der schuldfähigkeit geht ja ist ja
vielleicht nur eingeschränkt schuldfähig
hat ihm die sogenannte einsicht und
steuerungsfähigkeit bei der tat gefehlt
aber nur weil jemand ihre gedanken hat
heißt das nicht dass er freigesprochen
wird ja das wird uns wirklich so eine
störung sein dass er quasi stimmen hörte
die ihn zur tat getrieben haben oder
sowas und würde jetzt sagen
nachdem es ihr bisher gelesen haben so
ein ganz klares
unterschreiben er hat ja nicht gesagt
mir hat das jemand vor geflüstert würde
ich sagen das ist deutet nichts darauf
hin dass er wirklich jetzt schuldunfähig
wir haben vielleicht irgendwie
geminderte schuldfähigkeit das könnte
theoretisch
das ist viel zu früh das jetzt zu sagen
der täter hat sich ja auch
wahrscheinlich selber gerichtet von
daher kann ja gar nicht mehr schuldig
bestimmende kraft gelassen
dann gab es noch eine einer anleitung
von anna wie mobil
inzwischen muss sogar schon einen
amoklauf links oder rechts sein ihre so
felix du hast gerade schon gesagt ein
amoklauf ist das nicht kannst du
vielleicht das noch mal aus einer
juristischen sicht erklären weil es
etwas ein amoklauf und wenn es etwas ein
attentat das dann natürlich eine
politische ideologie dahinter hat also
der amoklauf bedeutet eben kurz tüte
wahllos irgendwelche personen fragt sich
wie oft das tatsächlich vorkommt auch
diese schul-amokläufer die richten sich
ja schon auch gezielt dann gegen
mitschüler gegen die man hasst also
letztlich ist es eine begriffs spielerei
wo man sich manchmal fragt wie wichtig
ist das jetzt für die opfer ist es
überhaupt nicht wichtig und für die
stadt auch nicht das war terrorismus er
hat hanau in angst und schrecken
gelegt und das wirkt er jetzt auch noch
nachricht das ist ja wahrscheinlich auch
sowas nenne das ja jetzt das liest man
in migrantischen communities menschen
mit die mit kopftuch sind haben ja auch
schon geschrieben dass sie angst haben
dass sie jeden dass auch merken dass sie
ausgegrenzt werden deswegen ist es
richtig finde ich sehe ich auch so der
sache nach ist es eben terrorismus und
juristisch geht es jetzt eine rolle weil
es noch weitere straftatbestände gibt
die sich eben gerade gegen die
bundesrepublik deutschland rechnen
staatsschutzdelikte bildung einer
terroristischen vereinigungen da geht
wirklich gezielt darum deutschland
anzugreifen
das ist so noch was noch zusätzlich
darauf hinzu kommt aber hier hat er ja
mord begangen mehrfachmord mutmaßlich
sodass und ist tot insofern spielt keine
rolle mehr aber hier wäre juristisch das
eigentlich nicht so relevant weil würde
sowieso wegen mordes lebenslang
verhaftet werden wir noch leben würde
die tat hat natürlich heute auch die
gesamte bundespolitik beschäftigt alle
parteien haben sich geäußert und sich
betroffen gezeigt auch bundeskanzlerin
merkel ist heute mittag vor die kameras
getreten und sie hat folgendes gesagt
der tiefe schmerz über den gewaltsamen
tod so vieler mitbürger denen die
menschen in hanau hält empfinden den
empfinde ich und den empfinden menschen
in ganz deutschland
ich denke jetzt vor allem an die
familien und freunde der ermordeten
niemand kann von uns ermessen welches
leid der täter über sie gebracht hat
ich trauere mit ihnen und spreche ihnen
meine tiefe anteilnahme aus rassismus
ist ein gift der hass ist ein gift und
dieses gift existiert in unserer
gesellschaft und es ist schuld an schon
viel zu vielen verbrechen von den
untaten des nsu über den mord an walter
lübke bis zu den morgen von halle
die bundesregierung und alle staatlichen
institutionen stehen für die rechte und
würde eines jeden menschen in unserem
land wir unterscheiden bürger nicht nach
herkunft oder religion
wir stellen uns denen die versuchen in
deutschland zu spalten mit aller kraft
und entschlossenheit entgegen
soweit also die bundeskanzlerin heute
mittag in ihrem statement ich sage jetzt
erst mal vielen dank felix dass du bei
uns war es uns die juristischen fragen
beantwortet hat man sieht ihn nicht mehr
steht aber noch neben und wir schalten
jetzt nach hanau live zu meinem kollegen
stefan schlosser der schon den ganzen
tag an einem der beiden tatorte steht
stefan wie ist denn derzeit die stimmung
in der stadt und am tatort
also die stimmung ist ehrlich gesagt
fürchterliche jetzt viele menschen haben
sich hier versammelt rund um den
großräumig abgesperrten tatort ndr sieht
man das ja dass der kiosk wo fünf
menschen erschossen worden sind heute
heute nacht das ist abgesperrt oder war
und während der mitten in einem
wohngebiet und überall an jeder ecke
stehen menschen und das haben sich auch
ganz viele angehörige freunde bekannte
der mordopfer hier zusammengetroffen
da hört man häufig wie menschen in
tränen ausbrechen laut auf weinen und
versuchen sich gegenseitig zu trösten
also die menschen sie sind wirklich hart
getroffen
auch viele nicht beteiligte die es
keinen angehörigen verloren haben sind
einfach nur schockiert anders kann man
das gar nicht sagen dass so eine bluttat
mit ihrer wohngegend in witten feuer
direkt vor ihrer haustür stattgefunden
hat viele wissen damit einfach auch gar
nicht umzugehen sie sind einfach
schockiert und vielen fehlen auch
wirklich die worte um das auszudrücken
was sie ihn ja was sie eigentlich im
moment bewegt sind seelsorger vor ort
werden die menschen irgendwie versorgt
unterstützt also grundsätzlich sind bei
solchen taten immer schnell seelsorger
der polizei vor ort die war mit
sicherheit auch heute nacht da direkt
nachdem die anschläge passiert sind
jetzt hier vor ort kann ich direkt keine
mehr sehen aber vor zwei stunden noch da
habe ich nochmal seelsorger hier gesehen
die das gelände gelaufen sind da kann
ich den aktuellen stand im moment nicht
sagen aber klar ist wer hilfe möchte der
bekommt sie auch also wenn die
angehörigen diese hilfe in anspruch
nehmen möchten dann würde man ihnen die
auch selbstständig zur verfügung stellen
du sagst die menschen haben nicht damit
gerechnet gibt es in der stadt geht es
den hanauer nichts so was wie eine
gelebte fremdenfeindlichkeit eine
rechtsextreme szene
das kann man nicht sagen das ist ja
gerade hier ein stadtteil in hanau
kesselstadt wo ich bin wo der
migrantenanteil sehr sehr hoch ist ja
hier sind viele menschen dann kann das
stück weit sagen auch unter sich ja
viele menschen mit migrationshintergrund
viele menschen haben einen türkischen
stücke stämmigen hintergrund da ist es
nicht so dass auffällig dass es hier
rechtes themen geht oder rechte
kriminalität gibt die ersten menschen
mit denen ich gesprochen habe die sind
sogar nach den ersten meldungen davon
ausgegangen dass sie sich vielleicht um
bandenkriminalität handelt ja weil das
ist ja ein stadtteil ja sagen wir mal
der ist vielleicht nicht zu den
schönsten in hanau
da gibt es vielleicht noch andere
gegenden wo die menschen ein bisschen
besser gestellt sind als hier
das waren die ersten gedanken vielleicht
ist es bandenkriminalität
kleinkriminalität vielleicht irgendwas
aus dem milieu die zu leicht um drogen
oder im glücksspiel das haben viele
gesagt war der erste gedanke und erst
nach und nach kam er dann die das
bewusstsein und kam die information dass
es offenbar ein attentäter ist der
rechtsextremistische motive hat und das
als die leute das erfahren da hat sie
eigentlich noch viel mehr schockiert
dass tatsächlich jemand hier wahllos
durch die gegend geht und menschen
umbringt erschießt nur weil sie einen
migrationshintergrund haben nur weil sie
ausländer sind ausländisch aussehen
fremd aussehen
das hat die menschen hier fielen wir
schockiert und das macht sie jetzt auch
unsicher so haben auch einige leute
gesagt meine mutter sagte mir zb hier
meine töchter
die gehen jetzt nicht vor die türe die
bleiben ist erstmal zu hause also so
etwas löst etwas in der stadt ausgelöst
etwas bei den menschen aus das kann man
überhaupt nicht wegdiskutieren ja jetzt
habe ich gerade auch den fehler gemacht
wir sind hier entschuldigen möchte weil
ich habe auch von fremdenfeindlichkeit
gesprochen ich habe mir wirklich
vorgenommen das nicht zu tun weil es im
grunde ja dieses denken des täters oder
der täter weiter trägt weil das sind ja
wahrscheinlich stefan menschen die nicht
wirklich fremd sondern die ihr ganzes
leben in hanau verbracht haben ihre
familien sind dort leben dort sind heute
wahrscheinlich auch geboren wurden was
ist über die opfer bei die reden wir ja
doch relativ wenig was weißt du da schon
ja das ist wirklich so viele menschen
mit denen ich eben auch gesprochen habe
also die sprechen die sprechen genauso
gut deutsch wie du und ich ja vollkommen
akzentfrei und sprechen sogar in
hessischen akzent
die sind im hier in hanau in deutschland
geboren wollen sind hier aufgewachsen
auch der kiosk besitzer er ist in
deutschland geboren ja das ist kein
ausländer er hat den deutschen pass aber
er hat einen migrationshintergrund aber
das ist eben auch alles ja er hat einen
deutschen pass
insofern ist diese die macht es eben die
menschen auch so betroffen dass das der
grund ist dass
der attentäter hier so zugeschlagen hat
also ich weiß jetzt das haben wir gerade
auch motoren im stück gehört dass ein
mitarbeiter des kioskbesitzers
erschossen wurde
sein neffe habe ich das richtig
verstanden weißt du noch wo die anderen
opfer quasi herkommen waren dass junge
leute waren dass anwohner also was
mittlerweile als bestätigt gilt dass
alle neun opfer die nicht mit dem täter
verwandt sind also es wird die mutter
wollte ja auch noch getötet und der
täter selbst dass alle neun opfer die
nicht mit den tätern in einer beziehung
standen migrationshintergrund hatten
und das ist ja ein starkes indiz darf
hier auch dass er diese beiden orte
aufgesucht hat die shisha bar am
heumarkt und hier hinter mir den kinos
unternehmen das ja auch noch eine shisha
bar dass er diese orte ausgewählt da
offenbar ging es ihm wirklich ganz
gezielt darum menschen mit
migrationshintergrund und vor allem auch
türkischstämmige menschen zu finden und
zu töten
das kann man einfach nicht weg
diskutieren und hätte er sich diese
beiden orte sicherlich nicht nicht
ausgesucht denn es war klar dass er
diese menschen hier antreffen würde
stefan wiertz dann heute weitergehenden
hanau
was passiert da heute noch also passiert
noch eine ganze menge ist haben wir
einmal den generalbundesanwalt gehört
ein paar informationen preisgegeben hat
hier in hanau selbst da ist viel politik
prominenz im moment unterwegs der
bundesinnenminister
horst seehofer in diesen minuten ist da
an dem anderen tatort am heumarkt
zugegen wird dort auch sein sein seine
trauer und sein beileid bekunden und
sich natürlich über die aktuelle lage
informieren
der hessische ministerpräsident volker
bouffier ist natürlich auch da durch
alle reihen durch alle böden durch alle
politischen parteien durch die gesamte
politik selbst im ausland haben sich ja
ganz ganz viele menschen zu wort
gemeldet und ihre wir ansetzen zum
ausdruck gebrachten ihre trauer zum
ausdruck gebracht ihre bestürzen heute
abend wird es eine mahnwache geben um 18
uhr hier in hanau am marktplatz und dort
wird auch der bundespräsidentin frank
walter steinmeier zugegen sein und
ebenso mit den angehörigen mit den
opfern mit allen die dabei sein möchten
trauert stefan dann bis hierhin erstmal
vielen dank für deine einschätzungen für
alles was du bist jetzt in erfahrung
bringen konnte ist und euch vielen dank
fürs zuschauen
den ganzen tag wird in zdf immer wieder
live darüber berichtet mit
sondersendungen
heute abend 1920 gibt es ein zdf spezial
gleich nach der normalen zdf heute wir
machen hier jetzt erst mal schluss und
sehen uns spätestens mit der heute plus
heute nacht wieder ich danke euch
[Musik]